can you explain Michael why you want the
government to be the Arbiter of Truth to
decide what beliefs I mean I've lived
through the government tell us there
were wmds in Iraq lie to us every which
way about covid and you are saying that
the government and the people that run
it should be an Arbiter of Truth and
then should involuntarily commit and
basically lock people up who don't need
their perception of the truth can you
explain to me as a matter of prudence
how that could possibly be a good idea
well I'm not saying that the government
is the Arbiter of truth of course not
but we have civil authority to establish
and to enforce laws and so we can either
establish and enforce laws on the basis
of pure will you know a man who says I
very much want to be a woman and so
that's what we're going to do completely
divorced from reality in the moral order
or we can establish and enforce laws as
a matter of interpretation to believe
that there is such a thing as objective
reality and a moral order and a natural
law that we are then translating into
the civil law traditionally in our
country and in all states it we have
pursued the ladder in in our age that
now seems to be increasingly untethered
from reality where people will mock the
very notion of objective truth we say
that that cannot happen but but to my
points earlier
the law will say something inevitably
the government is not some foreign
entity we live in America we have some
say in our government even still today
and and the law must necessarily say
something either the women get the
reason I keep going to the bathrooms is
because it's just so clear but you can
use the sports teams you can use I think
the involuntary commitment one is
relevant though because I think you know
this is not the level of force
it about about as I'm worried about well
I suppose right I mean bathrooms are are
smaller scale but what I would say is
that these issues are complicated and
they should be decentralized let let a
business decide their own bathroom
policies I've been to a lot of places in
Liberal cities that solve this by having
single stall unisex bathrooms fantastic
I will I don't have a one-size-fits-all
solution just random I'm going to stay
on the commitment
can feel
himself you know certainly the
government does draw lines around some
people who should be committed whether
due to risk to others or sometimes risk
to themselves I'm curious how you Mr
Palumbo feel the government should
respond is it right to commit someone
for treatment for anorexia which does
not put them as a danger to others
purely because we believe them to be a
danger to themselves to have a false
belief about their body I think there
has to be a very high threshold for
civil commitment we've seen it horribly
abused in the past in this country but I
think it has to be a direct danger to
themselves or others right their
physical safety so we've got trans or
not trans
somebody is a danger a suicide risk or
if they're a threat to others then we
can discuss involuntary commitment but
what we're talking about here is
essentially saying well we think
somebody has
in wrong beliefs so they should be
locked up I mean we should that would
have gotten that's the approach that had
people wanting to lock up and kill
Galileo for Derek to suggest that the
Earth was not the center of the universe
I don't think we know all know the truth
that's part of the process of
discovering the truth and let me just
say and I'm not saying this but a large
swath of the country thinks that the
Catholic faith believing in a God is a
deluded belief is a delusion they might
should they want to have you committed
no the majority of Americans still
believe in God not I don't think maybe
not in 50 years but today is still the
interest of the best this time I went up
the Galileo fisticuffs happen outside
and I will I will point out on that
point they did lock up Galileo and they
locked him up for being a jerk it had
nothing to do with his stupid scientific
book
s
for being politically uh Taking Chances
but what I want to ask here on this
question uh for a moment is
when it comes to these questions you
know there's
you've said it's hard to be sure right
you've said Mr Paloma that you're not an
expert in the science Mr Knowles you've
brought a number of citations with a you
know varying confidence in different
ones what is your greatest source of
uncertainty for each of you right now
about the current growth in transgender
identification in the roots of it and
what would you most like to know that
you don't know now well I I would just
like to correct you Leia you've said
that I've had varying degrees of
confidence in the scientific studies I
have no confidence in any of them I'm
just citing them because they back up my
art what would you actually like to see
study I mean it right like kudos for
honesty
I think you're right that this is an
issue that's been understudied because
no one does a randomized controlled
trial that's true of a lot of things
where we really care about the answer so
what would you most like to see studied
in the scientific context that you think
would help you and your opponents at the
end of it have a better understanding of
what's true I would most like to see
this issue studied not through biology
and not through some bizarre sociology
course in a gender studies department
but through anthropology and through
ontology and through philosophy because
ultimately what this comes down to I'm
happy that all the scientific studies
back up my view but I wouldn't really
care even if they didn't because the
question is what is the human person the
claim of transgenderism it keeps moving
but the claim basically is that one's
true self has nothing to do with one's
body so one can be in body entirely a
man but some deeper metaphysical level
one can be a woman and so the old way we
used to talk about this would be the
distinction between the body and the
soul and there's been a whole lot
written about the relationship between
the body and the soul the conception
that has dominated for at least 2 300
years and our civilization is an idea
called hylomorphism which is that body
and soul are united and sex derives from
the body and is an Inseparable accident
of the individual that persists and
applies to the whole person so that
that's to me a fascinating conversation
maybe eyes are glazing over here in the
room but the question that we're asking
here is what is a man what is a woman
and I I am uh not happy with the even
the conservative answer which is a woman
is a womb and two X chromosomes I don't
know what 2x chromosomes are if you told
me that a woman is sugar spice and
everything nice that to me is a much
more precise description and accurate
description of what a woman is so I'm
happy to have those conversations I
don't think that is the question I think
the question is who gets to decide well
you would have the government decide for
everyone and I would have people decide
for themselves in their own life let me
ask you that Mr Palumbo one question the
government does make a decision on that
arguably is a murkier question is when
is someone legally morally
intellectually an adult right
you know and that's something where the
government cannot remain silent we write
a lot of laws to draw a relatively sharp
line between children and adults even
though nothing magical happens on your
18th or 21st or for the purposes of
running for congress I think 25th
birthday
um but the law has to speak so how do
you think about when the law has to draw
a distinction how do you want it to draw
it I think that 18 is an imperfect legal
age of adulthood but it's the one we
have we should stick to it you're either
an adult or you're not and once you're
an adult you have the full freedoms and
rights and responsibilities that come
with our society and that should include
living your life in a way that
traditionalist conservatives don't
approve of think is wrong think is gross
think is bad but for minors I think it
is fair to talk about uh not nearly
enough safeguards on this care I
question whether they can even consent
to it but I think I think I have a
better sense right now for Mr Knowles
about how he would work through the
anthropological question of when should
the law set that limit you say you're
comfortable with the current one are you
comfortable with 19. if the if the
country were with you I mean it's
inherently arbitrary I would say just
has to be consistent right now we kind
of have a patchwork of things like 21
for some things 18 for some things 17
for some things I I agree it will be
fundamentally arbitrary I just think it
should be consistent so it could be 18
it could be 19 it could be 21. what irks
me is when it's inconsistent well what
I'm asking you just for a moment is
there's a question of is it inconsistent
with the question of is it correct and
I'm curious what do you drawn to answer
the question of is it correct yo you're
trying to draw them to some common
number but maybe you want that one to be
right you know what where do you get
your account of the human person to
decide what it means to pass into
maturity I think what we're talking
about when we talk about a legal age of
adulthood is your ability to fully
understand what's going around you your
brain development your ability to
consent inform consent to something
right and it I don't have a great way of
drawing the line that's not kind of
arbitrary but you do have to draw it
somewhere
I will allow Mr Knowles the obvious yeah
well I I don't I don't think that one's
view has to be arbitrary on this matter
I don't think my view is arbitrary I
just don't think transgenderism is true
and age we're talking about well but
this gets to age because for all of
human history pretty much no one has
thought that transgender the transgender
idea really is true and you don't seem
to think that it really is true it's
interesting well I think I view it
different I have a different definition
but here's the inconsistency that I I
find in your point you say that when you
turn 18 you ought to be able to chop
yourself up and put on a dress and go
into a women's bathroom and putting
aside the public issues that come from
that I just wonder how it is the case
that transgenderism is false for the
first 18 years and then suddenly becomes
true when one turns 18. and if that is
not what's really happening if it is
false and your trepidation in exposing
children to this is because it obviously
is false if it's false and harmful for
children why is it beneficial and true
for adults